en pleine nuit les soldats azéri
procèdent à des opérations de déminage
sur les routes enneigées du haut
karabagh c'est avec ces images que la
télévision azerbaïdjanaise annonce le
retour des forces de bakou dans le
district de calva jarre une présence
militaire renforcée tout au long de la
journée avec l'arrivée de centaines de
soldats pour l'azerbaïdjan
il s'agit du deuxième district restitués
par les forces séparatistes comme le
prévoit l'accord de paix signé sous
l'égide de la russie alors que de
nombreux arméniens ont choisi de brûlé
leurs maisons avant de quitter la région
le président azerbaïdjanais s'en est
violemment prise à regarder les choses
horribles qu'ils ont fait ces derniers
jours
en brûlant des forêts pour créer une
catastrophe environnementale
ces voleurs rabat des forêts y emmène le
bois en arménie pour le vendre ils
brûlent des maisons qu'ils n'ont pas
construite le district de cale baja
repasse ainsi sous la souveraineté de
bakou après celui d'agdam rendu le 20
novembre dernier un autre territoire
doit être rétrocédé aux forces azéries
le 1er décembre prochain le district de
latchine au total ce conflit a permis à
l'azerbaïdjan de reprendre sept
districts séparatistes du haut karabagh
de nombreux arméniens restant dans les
zones autorisées assure se sentir
désormais en en sécurité il y a toujours
du danger la guerre vient juste de
s'arrêter elle n'est pas encore terminée
comme on puisse dormir calmement alors
que notre ennemi se tient à seulement
200 300 mètres
ne devrait-il pas y avoir un no man's
land les azerbaïdjanais ont établi la
frontière à 200 mètres d'ici dix du
bétail franchi la frontière et ils ne
nous appartiendra plus les
azerbaïdjanais les emmèneront de leur
côté nous nous retrouvons sans bétail
c'était comme ça pendant l'époque
soviétique pour maintenir la paix la
russie a déployé près de 2000 soldats
dans le haut-karabagh une opération qui
a permis à des milliers de civils
se réinstaller dans les territoires
qu'ils avaient fui à cause des combats
de son côté le procureur général de
l'azerbaïdjan a annoncé l'ouverture de
plusieurs enquêtes sur des crimes de
guerre supposés perpétrés par chacun des
deux camps